house oversight committee member leading
the letter demanding the subpoena as we
just heard brook reference
congressman james comer thank you all
for joining us janice i want to start
with you i know you had that rally
yesterday i know you've been outspoken
about this for
almost a year now you've been passionate
about it you want
answers as do many others do you finally
feel like your voice is being heard
i do uh unfortunately it has taken 10
months but i suppose better late than
never
yesterday was um a good day there was a
lot of press
at that event i credit ron kim for
bringing the press there
fox news has been covering this the new
york post there have been some
journalists in albany new york
but this has been relatively uncovered
and this governor has been revered for
the last year
congressman great to see you as always
will this request that you have for
subpoenas
of governor cuomo be granted in the end
well who knows maloney's not been very
good at granting our request but
this is the job of the oversight
committee because if you'll remember
nancy pelosi created
a coronavirus select subcommittee
to investigate all things related to the
coronavirus mismanagement waste fraud
and abuse i'm sure pelosi was hoping
that that would involve the trump
administration but what the select
committee has found
the most concerning mismanagement and
form of abuse is at the hands of
governor cuomo with his nursing home
policy so we want answers and i know the
families of the victims want answers
janice you know you hear congressman
comer talking about this and his efforts
how much does this help your efforts to
have him and others supporting you
and trying to get these answers trying
to get them under oath as best they can
anyone that's trying to spread the
message and help our families
is you know another win for us
uh really it has to it has to resonate
at home
people have to understand the story it's
not hard to understand it
we had elderly uh that were infected by
the virus because
our governor had a mandate to put over 9
000 coveted positive patients into
nursing homes
and then he tried to cover up the
numbers not hard to understand at all
yeah it definitely isn't rocket science
we've been told to stay apart and they
put
people in places and did exactly the
opposite um congressman
how does the sad saga end
well the select committee is not going
to let up on this if you've been
following it steve scalise and jim
jordan
have primarily been highlighting this
they've been messaging this they've been
trying to represent
not just the families of the victims but
the taxpayers and the people of
new york so we're not going to let up on
this i think
maloney's going to cave under pressure
if you remember she represents new york
and the new york legislators both
democrat and republican including
ocasio-cortez
have called on the committee to
subpoena cuomo and to hear from cuomo so
i think cuomo has a lot of
questions to answer and i know the house
oversight committee and the
kova 19 select committee is not going to
let up on this hey janice what would you
say to people who don't support
this letter demanding the subpoena
this is not about politics it never has
been it's
not about republican and democrat it's
about what's right and what's wrong and
to ensure that this kind of thing never
happens to another family
again people needs to support this
janice i'll ask you the same question i
asked the congressman
how does this sad saga ultimately end
well i think our loved ones back
go ahead of course well
we're going to continue pressing on this
and i think that
democrats are good at eventually reading
public opinion the public opinion in new
york
is that people want answers and we need
to learn from history it's not about
politics this is about
finding answers this is about
accountability and this is about making
sure that something like this never
happens again
janice final word to you
that's it i wish i could have my
relatives back
but if i can lend my voice to those who
don't have one i will continue to fight
uh even when this isn't a news story
anymore i will
yeah and i know behind the scenes you've
been in touch with so many of the
the families who have been on this
program i know you reached out to me a
week ago saying i'm trying to you know
find their contact information to reach
out to them people we had on the show
and it's just been
um you know it's been devastating but
it's been truly remarkable to watch
all of your efforts everybody involved
janis dean congressman comer
thank you for joining us we appreciate
it thanks for having me